what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so continuing on with our series on
too powerful for the Marvel for Marvel
movies for the Marvel Cinematic Universe
I want to kind of swing for the fences
of obscurity here and talk about the
star brand because star brand is way too
powerful for the Marvel Cinematic
Universe here's a reason why so well
let's do a little bit of history here
because star brand is by and large
unknown to all but like the most
hardcore Marvel comic fans now those who
read Jonathan Hitler's Avengers and New
Avengers which by the way sidetrack for
a second no I did not forget about that
no I didn't drop it due to a lack of
interest we originally we had everything
scheduled out like I had everything
scheduled out from like the Thanos war
running all the way up to like Infinity
Gauntlet that infinity war I skipped
over infinity crusade because that story
sucks and then that would go into like
anihilation all these seven things the
problem is we did Infinity Gauntlet and
infinity war too fast we did that those
unlike Thanos war super fast faster than
we were supposed to and so we kind of
jumped ahead because that whole cosmic
landscape was gonna run up to Avengers 4
and that's when it was gonna stop you
know that's what it was basically an end
so we would have like this whole huge
playlist for ready to go back and watch
based on all the Marvel cosmic stuff so
we'll start that again here in the next
couple weeks and and yeah then we'll
work our way back up to you Jonathan
Hickman's Avengers the New Avengers
that's kind of where we're at at the
moment anyway so back in 1986 Marvel
really Jim shooter Marc Grunwald these
guys Archie Goodwin they had this idea
to create something called new universe
and new universe would basically be like
like the ultimate universe before the
ultimate universe it would be a wholly
separate universe in Marvel Comics
that would a crossover occasionally but
all the characters would be totally
unique and they would have like their
own histories and their own stories and
so on and so forth and it ran for about
three years between 1986 and 1989 and
then it came back in 2007 under warren
ellis but it was retitled to new
universal but in any event and the
original iteration and in the 2007
version what you saw was something
called the wide event and we didn't
really know the basis behind it all we
knew was that there was just something
called the white event and what would
happen is somewhere along the line
really those kind of like a big focal
point of the story is you would have
like this event that would be initiated
and it was you know Jim shooter and
Margaret Wald and Archie Goodwin's way
of basically saying here's how people
gain powers the issue with this is that
the naturist star brand was very
ambiguous back in the day it was just
like here's a guy with powers and they
were literally fleshing out his powers
as they were writing his character
because they had no clue what people
would or would not like again only
lasted three years there wasn't really a
whole
I think you could do this runs again
through new Universal and then it runs
up into Jonathan Hickman vineyards of
New Avengers so a little bit of a
spoiler here for those for those stories
those you guys who haven't read them the
way this played out was that the way
Jonathan Hickman explained it the
multiverse was basically created by
something called the builders by a group
called the builders the way the Hickman
does is it's kind of like they say they
did everything but there's been so many
different origins of the multiverse in
Marvel Comics at at this point it's
almost impossible to pinpoint which
one's the actual origin you go back and
you read some old x-men comics some sage
will tell you oh well you know the
Celestials who created the whole
multiverse and then you go and you read
something like like Al Huey's Ultimates
and then it was well there was the first
firmament the first universe which
created which fractured into like a like
an infinite number of pieces and that
created the first multiverse and you go
and you read like the old four stories
and it's like well you know the one
above all did it and so on and so forth
and it gets it gets really funky Doctor
Strange covers a lot of that stuff and
so there's a lot of origins there but
the way that hitman played this out is
he said there was a group called the
builders and these builders would
basically create things that were called
like a left
they were beings that existed out there
that served the purpose of like once the
builders created worlds they would go
and seed them so they would create like
plant life that would create like living
organisms different things like that
well one of the things that builders had
done is in anticipation of creating life
they created kind of like this
multiversal construct that was spread
across all the different universes
they're just simply call constructs that
existed in the super flow and the super
flow is basically the space between
universes right so if you were to take
like a like a peat like a like a
baseball and sit it on a desk and say
that's like this earth the earth that
you're in right now where you're
watching this video and you take another
baseball and you sit it like a foot away
from that one and you start filling up
baseballs and none of them are touching
you could say this space between those
baseballs is the super flow that is
basically the space whereby you could
navigate through that and go from one
one baseball to the next one earth to
the next within the super flow for each
one of these universes existed a
construct and if the time arose then the
construct would activate and it would
fire off a wide event and what that
would do is it would imbue somebody with
the power of the star brand now under
what conditions that wide event would it
would be initiated was relative and
Jonathan Hickman's Avengers the New
Avengers it was a collapse of the
multiverse and the occupants of the
constructs were just like fire them all
just shoot them all get you fire as many
white as many white events as you can we
need to get as many people out there
with star brand powers as we possibly
can and then that was the end of that
the the base of the satellites
was destroyed and then that was kind of
the conclusion of it but the idea is
that when a person is imbued with the
power of the star brand they're
basically given limitless power but
there's a caveat here so in Marvel
Comics you have different types of
powers right like you have static powers
you have user selectable dynamic powers
if there was such a thing and then you
have true dynamic powers what does that
mean okay static powers mean powers that
don't change
so take Wolverines healing factor for
example whether Wolverines shot with a
bullet or whether Wolverine is blown up
the rate of healing is exactly the same
the only thing that changes is how long
it takes to heal based on the injury he
sustains now from there you have like
user selectable dynamic powers which is
the best way I know how to describe that
but a really good example is someone
like Cyclops Cyclops his eyes are
portals to a dimension composed of pure
energy so when he opens his eyes
concussive beams come out now he can't
really control the rate at which that
energy comes out of his eyes because his
eyes are a fixed size he doesn't
increase the size of his eyes however he
can open and close his eyelids to let in
certain amounts of energy so if you were
to squint his eyelids he can make a very
concentrated beam that can punch through
a material or create like a hole in a
wall or something like that he can open
his eyes as wide as he can and blow a
mountain in half so there's different
things that he can do with regards to
his concussive blasts but his power is
quote-unquote controllable based on how
much of his eyes he opens then you have
true dynamic powers and those are powers
whereby a user cannot control the power
that he that they they possess and
that's the way star Brand works say for
example that like Thanos decided to
invade earth and star brand fights
Thanos star brand would not have access
to 100% of its power because having
access to 100% of his power to that
infinite amount of power would
annihilate Thanos and probably destroy
the earth in the process it's a way to
kind of keep his powers in check to have
a character that's there and then not
turn him into a caveat where it's not
always just sitting sovereign the star
brand will always win that's kind of not
what Marvel's shooting for it so so say
Thanos his power was equal to like 10%
of star brand's power just an arbitrary
number star brand would in turn receive
10.5% of his power now the question is
how does he received that well it's just
kind of the way it is that's really how
Marvel says it it's just the way the
star brand works it's not some being out
there that grants him his power it's
just kind of like this is how much power
he can access like mental blocks or
something like that that he just can't
move
Hastur she just can't move past and so
the result is that if star brand were to
fight Galactus and Galactus is equal to
like 50% of star brands power then star
ban would get like 51% just enough to be
able to defeat that foe now because the
power is limitless we're using arbitrary
numbers here I don't know what 50% of
infinity would be but the fact remains
that like you guys understand where I'm
coming from the power is always relative
now let's say for example that we remove
that that whole caveat let's say there's
someone like Professor Xavier it's the
star brand mark and using his vast
mental mental abilities removes whatever
those mental blocks happen to be or
whatever the case is and receives like
an infinite like the full brunt of star
Brandt's power it'll manifest itself in
a variety of different ways everything
from matter manipulation to reality
warping to superhuman flight speed
durability energy projection the whole
nine yards it's limited only by the
wielders imagination so whatever they
want to do they can do with that power
but again listen it's a way of keeping
star brand's powers under control so
like say it's a star Rand was gonna
fight Captain America Captain America is
just like a really strong guy who can
run really fast and punch hard and
that's basically it like he's a he's an
Olympian essentially if star brand were
to face off against Captain America he
would have control over his power in so
far that he could channel his power into
having like super strength and like one
hand or like one finger or something
like that limited to that scale whereas
if you were gonna fight like Galactus
well then it's a whole different beast
you know he's limited in imagination to
like conjuring beings out of thin air
that can like conjuring like a million
silver surfers to fight against Galactus
in his stead or something along those
lines there really is no limit to what
they can imagine and as a result the
powers can manifest themselves in
different ways the reason why this
becomes too powerful for the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is because one it
stretches the limits of credulity and to
a being like that would be nigh on
stoppable because no matter who they
face they would always win they would
always come out on top it's like Batman
for reasons that we can't explain the
Batman fans seem to ignore Batman always
wins and so it's one of those one of
those weird situations but with star
brand if Thanos shows up with a power of
the Infinity Gauntlet so our man would
have enough power to overcome the
Infinity Gauntlet and fan o's if
Galactus shows up on earth star ban
would have enough power to defeat
Galactus if you know the Silver Surfer
goes crazy gets the hammer of Thor and
is wielding the Infinity stones and
somehow manages to access the heart of
the universe stir around
enough power to overcome that it may
take a long time it could be that like
star brand doesn't fully know how to
utilize all those powers and in turn is
totally obliterated but the the nature
of star brand is to always adapt to
whoever it is that he's fighting which
means you you would essentially have a
movie where everybody else would be moot
there'd be no need for Ironman or for or
The Incredible Hulk or Captain America
or any of those guys because the man
will be a one-man army that's all the
way be you take that concept and you
combine it with someone who's super
smart like Black Panther or you give it
to someone like Tony Stark or you you
bring in someone that we haven't seen in
the MCU yet like Hyperion or the century
or somebody along those lines she's
already pretty much godly powerful in
their own right or even like Adam
Brashear who's basically super-smart and
basically godly powerful well then it
turns into who the hell is gonna stop
like no one's gonna get in there like no
one's gonna be able to stop them it gets
kind of crazy it gets it gets really
really bonkers but it really is a tried
and true definition of here's a
character who's basically a MacGuffin
hey we're in a situation we have to
write ourselves out of throwing star
brand if star Randall Wynn and and
people would hate that they would look
at that and say well that's ridiculous
like we like Batman because he's an
underdog because maybe he will lose we
know he won't because he's too popular
to be killed off but maybe he may be he
might be BBC might kill him often and
trick us and basically say actually he
wasn't dead he was just time displaced
but but nonetheless it's kind of
interesting with with this whole star
brand situation it's pretty wild the
only way to get him into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe would be to Cabot to
say that like his power is up to a
certain level right like his power is
equal to Thanos with like the Power
Stone and then that's it or like The
Incredible Hulk the strongest we've ever
seen him but then in turn like that
leads into questions like well how do
you how do you translate that into like
energy projection you know is the energy
projection powerful enough to like slow
down panels but not actually kill him we
haven't really dealt with like energy
projection in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so far you know those you guys
you don't know I mean it's literally
taking energy channeling it into a
physical force and sending it out into
someone we haven't really seen that yet
you know we haven't seen somebody do
that before everything for the most part
has been hands on fist on fist and
that's really been about it except for
the ebony maw which as much as I love
the MCU they completely screwed up and
he was using telekinesis what made the
ebony maw so dangerous in the end of in
Marvel Comics was the fact that he would
talk you into doing things you didn't
want to do he had the gift of gab he
could heat it like he he talked dr.
strange into summoning Schumer Gora of
being so powerful that like dr.
Strange's has always
biggest fear has always been if shoo
mcgrath or like you know zom or your mom
who were to show up in in like the main
model universe at full strength we would
all be screwed but but again you know
it's just one of those things where the
power's just too extreme it's just it's
way too vast to be able to do in a
believable way in a convincing way with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to come as explained make sure you guys
at the sub button to become part of the
Rob core if you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]